>> Hello, everyone.
Welcome to the third and final, for the time
being, TC39 panel we are doing at JSConf.
It's always a pleasure to come back.
We will introduce ourselves as we speak.
We collected your questions in the last couple
of weeks.
A little bit differently, we are going to
ask questions from the past years, so, that's
how the panel's going to work.
Let's give a round of applause for the panel
members.
[Applause].
As we get started, not everyone knows how
the committee works or what the committee
is.
There was a question that was asked in person
at one of our prep events that seemed quite
obvious, but it is a great question to start
with: what is the organisation behind TC39
in ?
>> Hi, I'm Aki, part of the chair group for
TC39.
I work for PayPal in Braintree.
TC39 is the 39th technical committee by the
name of a committee called Ecma International,
a standards body, like ISO, or that sort of
thing, and they publish the standard that
we work on as a committee.
That's the organisation behind TC39.
The committee itself is made up of people
who are sent by member organisations that
are companies and non-profits who are part
of Ecma.
We are considered delegates.
We either work for or are associated with
these companies that are part of Ecma International.
We work together and collaborate on what goes
into the spec, and how we are going to be
able to make improvements and changes, and
support all these different ways that JavaScript
is used.
>> Thank you, Aki.
And the next question that we are going to
do to set up the stage what TC 39 is and does
is how does a proposal move through the committee.
We have Jase here on stage who did a wonderful
talk about his Rust engine in JavaScript,
and he's been doing more work with the TC39,
specifically, he's been getting a proposal
through called All Settled.
Can you tell us about getting a proposal through
such a committee?
>> Yeah, I was quite lucky to meet a lot of
people on the committee last year in London.
I felt a lot started off with a conversation,
and talking to various members of the committee,
if there was an appetite for such a proposal.
It turns out there was.
That was a good thing.
Daniel, he has been helpful in putting me
in contact with the right people.
Not only that, but people who come from different
backgrounds as well.
That really helped.
It started off by a "straw person proposal"
which is a state zero which is a GIT repo
with identifying the problem space.
Then we managed to get a champion here, Matthias,
V8 - and stage one is identifying what is
the problem here?
What is the limitation and you and how we
can fix it.
It's not too important to have a solution
at this point.
We managed to craft something up that worked.
We had a small proposal that went through
- Matthias championed it.
For stage 2, myself and Rob from Bloomberg
both worked together on some of the specification,
and also getting more ideas from people as
well.
Also, another good thing is after stage 1,
we had implementation from Babel which is
really good which helps as well when you get
feedback.
Stage 3 is getting even more feedback and
thinking about a candidate release, and luckily,
I don't think there were too many sort of
rejections or limitations, and most people
seemed happy with it, and very recently, we
made stage 3 as well, and so now, I think
it's just getting some implementations in
browsers, and people can try it in Chrome
and Canary, and nightly.
Yes, hopefully stage 4.
>> You made this proposal not as a member
of the committee but as an independent contributor,
right?
>> Yes, absolutely.
I was become at the BBC at the time.
It was a limitation for me as a JavaScript
developer, and I thought if it's a limitation
for me, how many other people have this limitation?
One of those ways of working that out was
going to npm seeing how many people download
these packages, others languages have this
natively.
Can we do it in JavaScript?
Everyone here was friendly.
I had a conversation with members of the panel,
and they were very happy to champion it, and
we went from there.
>> And I'm going to ask you to introduce yourself?
>> Yes, Jason Williams, software engineer
at Bloomberg.
>> So, another question that we get sometimes
is we've got this whole proposal structure,
but how do we know it's implemented correctly
in browsers?
What is going on there?
I'm going to hand this over to Valerie, and,
if you could introduce yourself, and how we
do that?
>> I'm an open-web engineer.
I'm also the editor - the extension to JavaScript
called Ecma 402, the object that does pluralisation
and daytime formatting.
I help to maintain the test 262 test suite
which is ECMAScript implementations.
The test suite is about 35,000 tests which
test the individual tests, which test JavaScript.
Each test is a test file which has some metadata
about what line it tests in ECMAScript itself.
Each test is run twice.
There are really 70,000 tests, once in strict
and this is non-strict mode.
This report is showing how well the tests
are doing on all of the four four JavaScript
engines, and the tests are each in individual
tests files, so this is a directory structure
which shows the test structure that you can
find, and, if you want to look at the source,
you can drill down and look at individual
tests and whether or not they're passing,
and see the source code on the page of this
website.
Or you can go to our GitHub, TC39/test 2662,
and to get a standard in ECMAScript or a new
proposal in Ecma script, the last test is
to add to test 662 as well as the browser
implementation.
There are tests beak contributed, and all
the browsers can make sure they're in compliance
and passing the same tests.
It's a fun project.
[Applause].
>> Thank you, Valerie.
>> If I could add to that.
This is actually really an awesome resource.
Jason talked about implementing a JavaScript
engine, but for our major JavaScript engines
having something like this to be able to say
very easily when are we not being spec-conformant
is such an immense resource.
>> And can you introduce yourself?
>> Oh, yes, I'm Ross Kersling and I work at
PlayStation on our WebKit team.
>> Thank you.
So, this sort of rounds off our introduction
to how TC39 works, and we're going to be moving
on with community questions that you folks
asked, and we will start with one from last
year, asked by Sam Basson.
He asked, "I notice the committee's very heavily
dominated by Americans and American companies,
particularly Google.
Do you have any plans to become more representative
of the world, and only give certain companies
so much power?"
>> We're looking at how individual companies
and specifically individual spaces where we
get together in person are impacting those
contributions, and Ecma International, which
is the organisation we're part of, in fact,
is currently put an effort into helping us
find a way to be more inclusive internationally
in future years.
The 2019 meetings are already scheduled, but
2020 is being scheduled right now, and we
are going to work on finding a way of being
more inclusive.
>> Thank you.
That was a nice answer.
>> Hi, I'm Daniel Aaronberg, I work in our
compiler's team.
I think there is a real issue of this particular
kind of bias, that was identified, but I just
also want to point out there is heavy European
involvement in the development of the JavaScript
specification, both from people in Munich
V8 office, V8 from Bloomberg, and my company
based in Spain, and several others also.
We can build on that success, of course.
Julia based in Germany.
>> I'm based in Germany and Berlin, so, if
you have any complaints, you know where to
find me!
Thanks for that answer.
Moving along into more specific questions
about the standard, we have had several questions
about how long it takes to standardise things
and when do things come out?
Like how long does it take for a proposal
to go from stage zero to stage four?
>> I will take that one.
It can take a very long time.
The simple answer is years.
If you were to essentially - essentially,
you wouldn't really expecting to through our
staging process more than one per meeting,
and we do meet every other month, but, you
know, there's a lot to do in that time frame.
Implementing in Babel may take time, for instance.
The problem space you're addressing might
be quite clear but the solution may not be.
Maybe you need to revise that ultimate times.
Decorators might be a great example.
Finally, at the end of it all, before we can
say that we are all said and done, we need
this to be implemented - and shipping - in
at least two of the major engines, and you,
unless you want to implement that yourself,
might not have control over that time frame.
It can take a very lock time, and discussions
can get very heated, and so unless you have
a very simple, very uncontroversial proposal,
it will probably take on the order of years.
>> The next question we have is about when
are we going to get a standard library for
JavaScript?
>> So, from the way I see it, we already have
a standard library in JavaScript.
We have a bunch of functions, map, JSON, array,
a map set.
JavaScript has a pretty - well, I was going
to say a pretty big standard library but that's
not true.
That's what this question is really getting
at, is can we have a bigger and more standard
things in the library for JavaScript?
Should we put the standard library in modules
instead of where we are currently putting
it which is in globals?
And these are pretty interesting questions,
and I'm definitely supportive of exploring
them.
I've been working on them myself partially
from the website.
I am Dominic from the Chrome Team at Google.
Thank you.
And I want to mention our colleagues at Apple
have focused, adding these new standard library
features as built-in modules rather than built-in
globals.
>> We're looking into several concrete proposals
in TC39 about features to add to the standard
library.
You heard in Tara's talk earlier today about
recent additions like object from entries,
and there are other things that we are considering
putting in maybe built-in modules, or maybe
in the traditional way as properties of objects
that are connected to the global.
We're looking into Temporal which is a date-time
library which could make it so that you don't
need to use moment, looking into possibly
new ID standard library, or a library for
iterator helper methods, as well as methods
on set and math.
I think we are missing a bunch of things that
would be useful to have in the standard library,
so it would be great to have more help from
contributors about this.
>> Yes, I want to mention that some of these
library-type features have been some of the
most successful proposals in getting through
the process more quickly, so I mentioned that
features can take years, but we've also had
years that take six months or eight months,
because they're kind of just, oh, yes, everybody
agrees we should have a finally method on
promise, that kind of thing.
When we talk about the JavaScript standard
library, it's important to look at things
that are available across the ecosystem and
that ship with JavaScript run times everywhere,
and that include things like URL and text
browser which are in Node and other run times
if they wish to implement them.
There are a bunch of examples like that.
>> You will hear more about the integration
of URL and texting coder and browser web API
s in a talk later today.
We are trying to break down the barriers of
different standards groups and make sure we
can all work together to build a good JavaScript-centred
library.
[Applause].
>> Thank you, Dominic and Dan.
Moving on to our next question.
we have a question that's been given to us
anonymously, asking: often we are having discussion
that are related to proposals and larger questions
than TC39.
Yet Discuss is not being used.
Is there any plan to improve this?
>> Funny you should mention!
We are currently working on having a new discourse
instance.
It gives us an opportunity to be able to figure
out what people really are talking about so
that delegates who have limited time - and
we also have day jobs, we do this in addition
- can really engage with what the community
wants to talk about, and it will give us the
ability to have those conversations in public,
and hopefully be less of a black box to people,
because we really do want to engage with people.
It's just hard to find each other when what
we talk about can be so esoteric.
>> Actually, we have another slide here.
If you want to check that out, here's a QR
code, and you can go to that directly.
I will leave that on for a second.
Thank you, Aki.
Moving on to the next question, and we have
had this the last two years, which is on the
pattern-matching proposal.: I've not seen
any movement on the pattern-matching proposal.
Is it in an idle state?
If it lands as a statement, what will be the
heuristics to decide when using it or a chain
of if-else?
Do you think having pattern-matching as an
expression would be more beneficial?
>> That's a big question.
I'm Cat and one of the co-champions and co-authors
of the pattern-matching proposal.
The proposal has stalled right now.
These things take a lot of time right now.
Sometimes, what is hot right now - what is
at right now, it's waiting to be proposed
for a stage 2.
As soon as I get lead to show up for a meeting
and - get is ready for a stage 2.
As far as the statement versus expression
thing, that's a much harder problem.
We have Dan, actually, proposed a really interesting
solution to the statement and expression problem.
For those of you who don't know, like the
pattern-matching proposal currently is only
a statement, so it doesn't allow you to directly
assign from the pattern-matching theme because
it was it has ergonomics that are more spectacular
to other things like if, and else, and that
stuff.
>> It's hard to evolve the grammar of JavaScript.
There's a lot of things in it already, and
there are a lot of things that sort of happen
implicitly so, to sort of work through this,
there are various different solutions, and
that's sort of why a lot of these proposals
take time at TC39 because, for a big proposal
like pattern-matching, we need to consider
a lot of different alternatives to work through
these kind of technical issues, and find something
that's really going to be good again.
>> We have a second question about this from
last year.
Leonard Koch asks what are your thoughts on
reducing the capabilities of the pattern-matching
proposal expression to statement in favour
of cohesion?
>> So, I guess I kind of answered this already,
didn't I?
>> You might have.
Sorry.
>> I think I might have answered this already.
You know, the idea is I don't like the idea
that it's a statement.
I want to get something out there because
I would rather have a statement than no pattern-matching
at all, and my hope is that once we have it
as a statement, we can use that as justification
to bring more conditionals into expressions,
so that maybe we can start discussing, say,
bringing if-else into bringing an expression,
and then the trouble it's like the semantics
in the language don't make it particularly
easy to say what the result of a statement-like
thing will be if used in an expression position.
And kind of like there's one proposal that
is out there answering those questions, and
I kind of wanted that proposal at least to
start exploring that before giving us a solid
answer.
That's an expressions proposal, whether or
not it's required to wrap it with "do" is
up to the future, but we need to answer the
same problem regardless of these.
>> Next yes, moving right along into questions
regarding language design.
We had a question from Marvin.
This is also from last year: are there any
long-term goals?
What is the bigger picture for JavaScript
in the next five years?
>> Hi, I'm Shu, I work at Bloomberg.
So, JavaScript is many things to many people,
including all of you in the community here.
That is the same for us in committee.
It's many things to many of us in committee.
We have different personal visions and aesthetics
to what we want the language to be, and perhaps
we are also constrained by what our companies
would like the language to be for its use
case.
It is a committee language, so it's not a
one-author language where it's much easier
to kind of exercise your singular vision for
better or for worse.
So, the answer is it's really hard to say
what the five-year picture, or what the big
picture of what JavaScript is right now.
It's we are trying to work out a consensus
between the many different visions that people
bring to committee, and I want to - the usual
response to this when you hear this is it's
going to be a mess, and it's going to be full
of compromises, going to be full of things
that people don't like.
But I think in practice, JavaScript is eminently
useful, it keeps getting more and more popular,
used basically everywhere on the front-end
and the back-end.
We've done a decent job, and I would hope
that we can do a better job the a bringing
more cohesion, but there's going to be no
singular vision going forward.
It's going to be difficult to get that but
I hope to have consensus on practicality,
and what is most important thing at the time.
>> Thank you.
The next question we have is about how transpiling
impacts JavaScript, and specific questions
are foals: JavaScript has become the target
of many compilers.
How does this fact influence your work on
the language in general?
>> I work on Babel.
I
think it is what it is being able to use features
before they're implemented, an opportunity
for all in the community to work out involved,
testing them out in the early stages, although
we warn against doing that in production,
and just being able to be a part of - you
don't have to be on the committee, but being
able to be involved - yeah.
>> Thank you.
And moving on to the next one from Soran:
when writing new features, where do you look
most for inspiration?
Other languages?
Which ones, in that case?
Or is it mostly driven by requests from the
community?
>> Very quickly, again was the answer is many
things to many people, but for me personally,
I've always very much wanted to bring new
capabilities to the language on the web that
it could not do before, like what we have
done with shared array buffers to bring shared
memory programming to the web, and as we hope
to do soon, ...
>> I want to second what Shu said, but from
my perspective, as somebody who represents
the Chrome team, we're interested in what
makes programming on the web easier, and so
when we think about new features, we're like,
what are people commonly doing?
What shows up popular - what is a popular
pattern for writing websites that is hard
because of JavaScript today?
An example proposal which I kind of started
but never really followed through on is something
called blocks where it's we want it to be
easier for people to write web workers inline
in JavaScript because we think concurrency
is important on the web.
Things like that is one motivating factor
that at least one member of the committee
tries to use to govern this process.
>> Thank you for that answer, Dominic.
The next question is from Mark, with the new
operations and features being added to JavaScript,
is there a risk that the language will have
too cryptic a syntax for new developers.
Web development being approachable is a big
boon.
>> I will try to answer this as quickly as
possible.
We do this strongly with each proposal.
We have a notion of a syntax budget which
simplifies the idea that there is only so
much syntax you can take before being overwhelmed
in using a language, so we want that to be
comfortable.
We don't want to overshoot that, but we do
want to make use of new syntax where it really
is worthwhile.
>> We will have a couple of quick back-and-forths.
>> Sometimes, adding just a little bit of
new syntax can make programming easier.
Like a lot of programmers are exciting about
the optional chaining proposal where you use
question mark dot.
Even if it is undefined, it still works.
Adding new syntax can make things easier to
programme.
We consider this as a trade-off, not an absolute.
>> Thank you.
So thank you very much to everyone who is
on the panel, and thank you all for being
such a wonderful audience.
As always, we are looking for different ways
to help people participate in the process
and also help us get the best data.
One thing that we are doing right now is an
experiment that's currently running.
I forgot that side was there.
We currently have an experiment running.
If you want to participate in it, here, this
is very finicky, here is -- please feel free
to go to the URL and take the survey.
It will help us whether or not experimental
data works for the committee process.
That's all for our panel.
Thank you so much, everyone.
[Applause].
Oh, one last thing: anyone who has further
questions and didn't manage to get their questions
in, we will be in the corner over there taking
more questions if you want to talk to us directly.